contes à 1 % de cas dans le monde sait
très peu comment vous l'expliquez nous
devons considérer que les chiffres sont
sous-estimés mais nous ne sommes pas
encore au niveau où se trouve par
exemple les robes pour les états unis
quelle stratégie vous avez déployés dans
le sud kivu pour limiter la propagation
du virus on a proposé à ce qu'est le
confinement plus être sélectif est
concerné seulement des personnes âgées à
haut risque de complication pour
sensibiliser la population
ça l'est beaucoup plus facilement
puisqu'on venait de sortir d'une d'une
épidémie d'ebola qui exige également la
distanciation social lavage des mains
qui était si on aura affaire à deux
épidémies aussi dangereuse qui est des
mollahs et coronavirus ça pourrait être
très très difficile pour nous
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue sur rt france
pour deux heures d'émission nous
décrypterons comme chaque soir du lundi
au jeudi
l'essentiel de l'information avec nos
invités et nos reporters sur le terrain
l'actualité toujours dominé par la crise
du coronavirus en france et dans le
monde
voici les titres en france un week-end
prolongé et des inquiétudes les
autorités redoutent un afflux de
promeneurs ils pourraient favoriser une
flambée de l'épidémie
les contrôles des forces de l'ordre sont
donc renforcé sur le plan politique
edouard philippe doit se prononcer d'ici
à samedi sur la tenue du second tour des
municipales crise des gilet jaune crise
du coronavirus les commerçants petites
ou grandes enseignes ne sont pas
épargnés ces derniers temps en dépit à
des aides de l'état les options seraient
une parfois au dépôt de bilan les
demandes de placement en redressement
judiciaire ou en procédure de sauvegarde
ces commerces dont dépendent des
milliers d'emplois peuvent-ils survivre
aux coronavirus sera l'objet de notre
face à face c'était le 17 mars à les
frontières externes et internes de
l'espace schengen fermé face à la menace
invisible du cornât virus à l'heure du
décompte finement c'est bien sûr la
question inverse qui se pose comment
rouvrir progressivement les frontières
et faire repartir les échanges
économiques et touristiques en toute
sécurité
claude blanchemaison nous apportera son
éclairage
chute du tourisme de l'aérien
contraintes sanitaires nouveaux modes de
consommation l'épidémie au bord a
bouleversé bon nombre de modèles
économiques alors quelles seront les
gagnants quels seront les perdants de
cette crise et avec quelles conséquences
économiques
l'économiste jacques sapir tentera d'y
répondre dans sa chronique est qu à
20h45
[Musique]
ce week-end prolongé de l'ascension et
il le week-end de tous les dangers c'est
quatre jours ensoleillés font craindre
en tout cas un afflux de promeneurs avec
un risque de relancer l'épidémie hier le
ministre de la santé a constaté une
accélération des regroupements olivier
verront se veut extrêmement vigilant il
est trop tôt dit il pour tirer des
conclusions sanitaire de la levée
partielle du confinement
les contrôles sur les routes devraient
être nombreux pour faire respecter la
fameuse limite des 100 km autour de son
domicile un et autre interrogation poste
confinement la question du second tour
des municipales
aura-t-il lieu en juin vous faudra-t-il
patienter jusqu'en janvier 2021
ce sont les deux dates possibles
avancées hier par le premier ministre
edouard philippe qui a rencontré donc
des chefs de partis politiques hier soir
le premier ministre doit faire connaître
sa position avant samedi
si plusieurs responsables appellent à ne
pas précipiter les choses d'autres au
contraire souhaité organiser ce scrutin
le plus rapidement possible
c'est compliqué d'organiser une élection
sincères sont rencontre entre candidats
et électeurs
cela risque d'éliminer tout débat
démocratique avec une campagne
particulière sans réunions publiques
sans distribution de tracts une partie
de l'électorat au rappeur de voter à
partir du moment où les conditions
sanitaires sont réunies je suis
favorable à ce que les élections se
tiennent le plus rapidement possible et
notamment en juin s'il n'est pas
possible de faire une campagne
électorale
un scrutin ne peut pas avoir lieu deux
blocages pour juin un blocage sanitaire
parce qu'on n'a pas encore le bilan du
déconfinement et un blocage démocratique
les français ne sont pas prêts à aller
voter après le fiasco du premier tour il
n'y aura pas de campagne il y aura très
peu de participation c'est très partagée
dans tous les partis
chez nous c'est du 50 50 on souhaite que
les élections se tiennent le plus tôt
possible
c'est très difficile de se prononcer
dans la mesure où eux ont accès à des
informations que nous nous n'avons pas
neuf jours après le déconfinement il est
encore trop tôt pour dire si oui ou non
on pourra voter le 28 juin
et pour en parler nous sommes avec jean
christophe lagarde président de l'ue des
e-bonds soir jean-christophe lagarde
merci d'être avec nous en direct sur rt
france vous étiez donc cette réunion
hier soir autour du premier ministre est
manifestement bien d'entendre un vous
n'étiez pas tous d'accord
comment ça s'est passé haut la réalité
c'est que la plupart des partis
politiques étaient d'accord parce que
d'abord le but c'est vrai aussi
d'ailleurs à lui dit dolan finir veulent
dire bon allez on tourne la page mais je
crois que ça n'est pas responsable s'est
dit herman d'abord parce que vous me
demandez comment ça s'est passé hier le
président du conseil scientifique
confirmée par le premier ministre nous a
expliqué qu'ils allaient prendre la
décision alors qu'on ne connaît pas
l'état sanitaire du pays
après le comte déconfinement qui a
commencé il ya une dizaine de jours ça
veut dire qu'en réalité ils sont en
train de relancer une ont décidé dans la
réalité vous voulez coûterait demain de
relancer une élection sans savoir où on
va à tel point d'ailleurs que le 27 mai
ils vont convoquer les électeurs par
décret qui devront dire voter le 28 juin
mais le 13 juin après trois semaines de
campagne on va dire on va faire un point
parce que si ça se trouve on est obligé
de tout annuler ça ne paraît pas
raisonnable
ça ne me paraît pas responsable d'un
point de vue sanitaire et puis c'est
aberrant d'un point de vue démocratique
parce que la deuxième chose qui a
expliqué le conseil scientifique c'est
que évidemment et ça nous le savons bien
le jour du vote on peut sécuriser des
électeurs mais le problème c'est la
campagne le mois de campagne
d'ailleurs avec les rumeurs qui ont
couru bail et candidats sont déjà
repartis en campagne pendant un mois de
campagne
en fait le conseil scientifique dit faut
modifier les règles faux pas de réunion
publique faux pas de rencontre entre les
candidats les électeurs faux-pas de
distribution d'un tract parce qu'un
papier dont il est contaminée ils
restent contaminées entre 24 et 48
heures bref en fait faut pas
communiquions faut pas discuter du
projet et de quelles élections parle
t'on g
on est en train de parler de l'élection
qui peut qui décident de ce qui se passe
au coin de votre rue
dans l'école de vos enfants dans les
équipements sportifs et culturels que
vous utilisez c'est justement la seule
élection où les français peuvent
vraiment échanger des candidats et là
ils veulent organiser une élection sans
discussion entre les candidats et les
électeurs
pire encore la réalité c'est que une
partie de la population notamment
ag dont le conseil scientifique répète
il l'a dit encore hier qu'elle est la
plus à risque ne va pas venir voter et
de quelle commune parle dont on parle
des communes où le score est serré
puisqu'il n'y a pas eu d'élu au premier
tour où ça se terminera peut-être à
quelques voix à quelques dizaines de
voix et il ya des centaines de personnes
qui n'ont pas voté ce scrutin ne pourra
pas être sincère dans ces conditions là
donc on est en train d'organiser sans
savoir où on va une élection qui
peut-être s'arrêtera en cours de route
est en réalité pour la convenance des
partis politiques pour la convenance des
candidats je crois moi que les français
ils n'ont plus du tout l'esprit aux
élections qu'on peut largement et
facilement atteint 9 mois pour
l'organiser dans des conditions
sanitaires scène avec un vrai débat
démocratique qui permettent à chacune et
à chacun des français de choisir leurs
maires en connaissance de cause pas là
dans le brouillard dans l'absence dans
la peur jean christophe lagarde tout de
même ce n'est pas un peu dissonante
d'attendre janvier 2021 c'est vrai que
c'est dans longtemps il y aura plusieurs
élections notamment la présidentielle
qui s'enchaînera l'année d'après le chef
des républicains évoque notamment de
repousser pardon d'un an toutes les
commandes publiques avec des
conséquences en termes d'emplois
importante qu'est ce que vous lui
répondez
alors pour la deuxième question je vais
dire mais c'est absurde pour le première
dame j'ai été élu maire en 2001 le
mandat devait s'arrêter en 2007 mais y
avait les élections présidentielles donc
le mandat a été prolongé jusqu'en 2008 à
cause de l'élection présidentielle
est-ce que vous ne croyez pas que la
situation que nous vivons c'est pire que
l'élection présidentielle est ce que ça
ne justifie pas plus on retarde de neuf
fois une élection qui de toute façon
avec la façon dont la fin de semaine
s'est déroulée du 1er tour n'a déjà plus
grand sens puisque plus aucun aucun
français ne se souvient de ce que
disaient les candidats y apprends moi
vous croyez pas qu'ils ont eu autre
chose à faire pendant le confie
demandons aux craintes d'autres
préoccupations et même les candidats
comment pourrait-il avoir le même
programme après locaux vides qu'avant le
coc vide ça n'est pas sérieux
quant à l'argument évoqué sur les rubans
l'économie
pardon il ne tient pas debout quand vous
êtes maire si on prolonge le mandat le
on a des mères actuelles de neuf mois
ils ont leur projet ils ont leur
programme
il continue à avancer c'est bien armes
d'ailleurs ils sont candidats pour être
réélu et quand ils ont réélu ben ali
n'ont pas attendre un an deux ans pour
lancer leurs projets donc ça le retard
de rien pour lé maire sortant qui sont
en place et si un changement politique
dans la ville mais figurez-vous que le
maire carrier pour pouvoir lancer le
moindre projet il va lui falloir 18 à 24
mois pour organiser ces kids équipe pour
définir précisément le projet pour
trouver le concepteur l'architecte ou
autres du projet définir un programme
trouver l'argent c'est 18 à 24 mois que
je parle d'expérience j'ai été maire
pendant 17 ans non ça c'est un mauvais
prétexte parce qu'il ya évidemment et je
le comprends et y compris dans ma
famille politique des élus qui veulent
en finir pour pouvoir travailler
différemment
sauf que ça escamote le débat
démocratique et sa faire courir un
risque sanitaire à la france
sauf que certains eux évoquent le
confinement de la démocratie si on ne
vote pas en quel cas notamment des
socialistes qu'est ce que vous leur
répondez
parce que la démocratie a confiné comme
les électeurs peuvent pas rencontrer les
candidats
quand les candidats peuvent pas aller à
leur rencontre pour expliquer ce qu'ils
vont faire ça c'est un système
démocratique
très franchement ça finit par ressembler
à ce qu'on a connu dans d'autres régimes
dans d'autres pays où en fait il ya
peut-être des élections mais c'est
faciale c'est à dire que vous avez le
choix enfin pas vraiment puis vous savez
pas sur quoi vous choisissez on nous
parlait hier d'autoriser beaucoup plus
massivement les procurations
ah oui mais ça veut dire quand même
qu'il faut que les gens puissent poser
des questions vous savez quand on vous
dit qu'on va refaire tel ou tel
équipement public celles et ceux qui
vont payer les contribuables qui sont
aussi les électeurs ils ont droite et
changer peut poser des questions enfin
pardon soit on dit qu'on fait une
campagne électorale et alors il faut
faire campagne et la campagne save
l'échangé la discussion
c'est parfois des disputes entre les
citoyens et les candidats qui ont des
choses à faire valoir et les
explications à donner là donc on fait
campagne électorale ça rend bail vous
avez vu ça dans quel pays ou merci jean
christophe lagarde avoir été avec nous
en direct sur rt france 1 et 2 puis le
décompte
il ment les français ont changé leur
mode de consommation une tendance qui
profite aux grands en scène et qui
laisse les petits commerçants en
difficulté mais pas que précision en
images
[Musique]
peu
e
oh
[Musique]
là
oh
peu
[Musique]
oh
à
et le gouvernement a décidé la mise en
place d'un plan de 100 milliards d'euros
destinée à sauver des entreprises
françaises son objectif était zéro
faillite zéro licenciement pendant leur
confinement
quinze jours après le début du
déconfinement de grandes enseignes sont
elles aussi menacées la halle andré
alinéa naf naf et la situation n'est
malheureusement pas meilleur chez les
petits à la suite de cette crise du
coronavirus à leurs questions après
cette crise inédite les commerçants ont
ils une chance de s'en sortir c'est
l'objet de notre face à face ce soir
[Musique]
pour en débattre nous sommes avec
francis palombie président de la
confédération nationale des commerçants
de france bonsoir francis pas leur vie
merci d'être avec nous à ses côtés
guillaume bigot directeur de l'ipag
business school merci à vous aussi
d'être là guillaume bigot soit il et
bienvenue sur notre antenne la question
ce soir il va y avoir beaucoup de morts
selon vous combien d'entreprises
combien de commerces vont devoir fermer
on commence par vous you me bigot
c'est totalement impossible à prévoir la
seule estimation on est éthique une
estimation macroéconomiques
c'est un recul à minima de 8% du produit
intérieur brut français qui peut aller
jusqu'à 10% ça va dépendre justement des
conditions de déconfinement de
déconfinement sera plus ou moins rapides
ou pas voilà ce qu'on peut dire c'est
une âme c'est une agrégation maintenant
il est bien évident que si on regarde
dans le détail mais si on prend la
question question très importante bien
sûr celle du commerce
on est on est forcément tout de suite
confrontées à la haye au constat que les
grands des grandes enseignes
toutes choses égales par ailleurs vous
avez cité dans l avance de votre sujet
les enseignes sont effectivement déjà
impacté alors qu'ils sont néanmoins
grandes et moyennes surfaces importantes
mais enfin que le ballon les grandes
enseignes d'abord la grande distribution
d'abord des géants comme carrefour ont
été vues par des profiteurs parce qu'ils
l'ont pas fait exprès mais ils ont été
bien des vidéos avantagé par les
compliments
et l'essentiel du trafic l'essentiel la
consommation est reporté mr s'étendant
taille donc il est bien évident que là
elles ne seront pas particulièrement
atteinte par la crise du coc vide au
contraire elles ont été stimulés par la
crise du colis de plus les conditions
sanitaires qui sont imposées par le
gouvernement
plus c'est dans ces lieux sont
importantes plus les groupes sont
importants et structuré et plus il est
facile pour les enseignes de s'adapter
et finalement aux conditions de
déconfinement donc on peut considérer
que ce qui va être le plus critique en
fait ce sont les petits commerçants sur
les commerçants de détail etc
voilà les gens ces gens là d'abord parce
que en raison d'un chiffre d'affaires
plus petit mais en raison aussi d'une
fermeture totale pendant le confinement
ils vont avoir beaucoup de mal à
redémarrer oui justement française
palombes il est petit on en parle vous
avez repris dans la grande majorité à
votre activité le 11 mai dernier
quels sont les premiers retours on a vu
que les magasins étaient ouverts à ce
que les clients eux ont répondu présent
alors d'abord les entreprises et des tpe
du commerce que je représente à hauteur
de 450 milles ont repris vraiment avec
une force et une fois intense ils se
sont préparés avec l'aide du
gouvernement sur le plan des mesures de
protection ils se sont préparés ils ont
mis en place toute l'infrastructure
c'est vrai que ils sont davantage
impacté
parce que les surfaces de vente que son
petit ce qui est plus difficile à gérer
au niveau de la différenciation donc ça
c'est un problème mais pour autant nous
avons ouvert content d'ouvrir fort de
vouloir partir et de poursuivre
l'activité du commerce
je pense que il faut aussi noter c'est
un point positif malgré ce qu'a dit
monsieur il est tout à fait dans la
logique des choses
et bien c'est que par peur de contracter
le virus
à l'heure d'aujourd'hui malgré que les
grandes surfaces ont été visitées temps
dans le confinement fortement et les
sites internet les plateformes amazon et
j'en passe mais quand même maintenant
que c'est réouvert on vient
les centres vide peut être encore plus
volontairement et facilement que dans
les périphéries les grandes enseignes ou
quand même le confinement est peut-être
plus dangereuse certainement plus
dangereux que dans les magasins
individuel que sur les marchés que nous
avons donc nous avons demandé fortement
la réouverture des marchés ont été très
affectés pourtant il n'était pas
dangereux avec le maintien de règles
bien sûr intrinsèque
donc j'ai des chiffres aussi vous les
voulez il ya des régions qui ont été
plus impacté que d'autres camps moins
bien recommencer par exemple poitou
charentes 42% de moins en moyenne
sinon la fourchette et entre 25 26 27%
de moins jusqu'à 42 % principalement
poitou charentes et il ya un engouement
bien sûr dans les grandes villes dans
les rues mythiques vers certaines
enseignes qui ont mis en place comme
vous pouvez vous en douter des
promotions important on va aller je te
l'envoie en dit pas ce qui se passe sur
le terrain on sent des ailes et
interroger ces petits commerçants dont
vous parlez francis palombes y plusieurs
commerçants de bordeaux notamment
écouter leurs réactions
c'est une très très grande inquiétude
quand on est entrepreneur c'est qu'on
aime aussi laventure mais là y'a quand
même des les contraintes qu'on maîtrise
pas et
et encore moins que d'habitude on sait
que ça sera pas positif en tout cas
puisqu'on a arrêté totalement l'activité
depuis le 15 mars
on est vraiment dans le doute et on voit
les choses un peu au jour le jour
matin après matin mais plutôt pessimiste
on est vu on a une perte de chiffre
d'affaires entre 70 et 85 % sachant
qu'on était en augmentation depuis trois
ans et la cam à 27 ans donc même si on a
une cave on a une cliente grosse
clientèle de fidèles étrangers et locaux
on n'est pas très optimistes donc on
cherche à se renouveler
voilà on se met en question à trouver de
nouvelles idées pour dynamiser notre
offre et du coup l'intérêt de la
clientèle actuelle et potentielle à
venir les deux derniers mois n'ont pas
été faciles et on n'a pas trop de
visibilité quant à la réouverture donc
nous on essaye de s'attacher à ce qu'on
puisse rouvrir dans les meilleures
conditions donc on essaye de
de retaper un peu le bar dans lequel on
etc et on essaye de ne pas penser au
pire
parce que de toute façon nous on peut
rien y faire on n'a aucune prise là
dessus donc on fait ce qu'on sait faire
et on croise les doigts quoi donc c'est
sûr que c'est des motifs d'inquiétude
mais on essaye nous de près dans tous
les cas et puis on verra bien ce qui se
passe ni guillaume bigot on voit que
l'optimisme de francis e ballon be a été
un petit peu tempérée par ses réactions
de deux commerciaux ont forcément
inquiet votre regard d'expert est ce que
le gouvernement fait le maximum
justement pour soutenir ces petits
commerçants où il aurait pu en faire
encore plus non le gouvernement hérite
enfin totalement pieds et poings liés
par à la fois les traités européens à la
fois là les contraintes de la zone euro
qui sont imposées c'est à dire que healy
amine dia il ya une attention
particulière qui est portée dans le
cadre des stratégies araki celle de la
construction de l'union européenne et
une attention particulière même si on a
laissé flotter si vous voulez les
déficits au delà 3%
ça ça a été confirmé il ya quand même
une attention qui est porté à ne pas
aller trop loin dans le déficit
ce qui fait que pour être précis la
france a réinjecté à injecter bons sons
milliards d'euros au service de ces
petits commerces ou petites entreprises
etc
c'est à rapporter à l'aide dépasse
maintenant 500 milliards qui a été
consenti outre-rhin
alors on répondra bien sûr que la
situation des finances publiques en
france et en allemagne n'est pas la même
elle entend bien mais néanmoins si
l'histoire n'est pas considérable
il n'y aura pas de récupération je
m'explique d'abord on a parlé des
conditions du des compliments c'est vrai
que ces contraintes sanitaires sont
encore importants donc le virus circule
et donc c'est une menace
ça va rendre la reprise plus compliqué
plus difficile mais néanmoins ce qu'il
faut bien avoir en tête c'est que le
l'absence de consommation pendant deux
mois plus de deux mois qui est la durée
des compliments du confinement pardon si
vous prenez l'exemple d'un restaurant ce
restaurant n'a pas servi de couverts
pendant deux mois
même s'il ya un chômage partiel et
l'essentiel de l'aide
si ce temps le chômage partiel même s'il
y a d'ailleurs une disons une politique
est tout à fait favorable au fait de ne
pas rembourser les cotisations et les
aides sociales etc
en aucun cas il y aura une récupération
ce chiffre d'affaires qui a manqué ce
qui veut dire que même lorsque les
restaurants les cafés et tous les petits
commerces pourront rêver les rangs des
conditions normales il faut évidemment
pas s'attendre
est ce que les clients consomment quatre
fois plus pendant deux mois ont récupéré
le manque à gagner
autrement dit ici n'est pas de
réinjecter pas par une politique
macroéconomique expansive
ce manque à gagner il ne sera jamais
récupéré en chocolat noir ou un
gouvernement très contraint par ses par
ces contraintes européennes françaises
palombes même un même analyste
oui très proches de monsieur mon analyse
nous demandons déjà au gouvernement
d'être très vigilant d'un camp de
continuer à accompagner les entreprises
et là c'est bruno le maire a été
exemplaire dans son action avec sa
secrétaire d'état en espagne et une
fille il ya une vraiment une volonté de
ceux de soutenir les entreprises mais si
ça s'arrêtait dans les deux mois qui
suivent
c'est cet accompagnement c'est ce suivi
de l'évolution de la reprise du fida
père et sa soeur récupérera pas en deux
mois
né en trois mois ça se récupère à dans
une une bonne année au minimum et et
donc il faut une continuité du soutien
aux entreprises notamment les
restaurateurs sont affectés encore plus
que les autres c'est vrai qu'il ya un
plan spécial pour eux c'est vrai qu'ils
ont été reçus par le président de la
république et c'est pour cette raison qu
en ce qui me concerne ça va interpellé
monsieur favorablement la leyre de
parfaitement bien connaître le mécanisme
commercial et vous remercie de vos
propos nous demandons à ce que les
soldes d'été soir eau pour repousser
d'un mois par rapport à la normale
pourquoi tout simplement parce qu' une
petite entreprise n'a pas la même
structure n'a pas le même modèle
économique qu'une grande chaîne quand
groupe même s'ils souffrent eux aussi
mais ils ont des infrastructures
ils leur permettent d'affronter la
situation différemment française
pardonnez moi vous demandez aussi la
solidarité commercial des grands groupes
à ne pas faire de grosses promotions y
compris sur internet vous pensez que
vous allez être suivi alors très
franchement j'ai cru quelques moments où
tout début quand vous allez déjà
interviewé une première fois mais la
solidarité commercial je n'y crois pas
je n'y crois plus tout au moins mais par
contre le report des sols de nous y
tenons et je répète quand même à votre
antenne qu' il ya des grandes chaînes
qui vendent actuellement alors que nous
ne sommes pas en soldes à -70% ça
correspondrait schématiquement à une
vente à perte s'était formellement
interdit par la loi
on ne peut vendre à perte que pendant
les soldes
alors j'ai alerté le ministre de
l'économie
ilan et conscience j'ai demandé à la
dgccrf d'apporter contrôles réguliers
pour que en reste dans la légalité même
si on ne peut pas empêcher les
promotions depuis le 2015
depuis 2008 2015 de monsieur je sais
très bien on a libéralisé en relation
avec l'europe donc les promotions sont
tout à fait possibles bigot mais
pardonnez moi parce quils le mois de la
fin français sa langue et parce que je
crois qu'il faut libérer la nouveau pour
eux voilà allez-y ouais écoutez je le
mot de la fin je vais le donner parce
que je dois vraiment me libérer dans
quelques instants pour un autre
interview je dis qu'on va s'en sortir
mais à condition que le gouvernement
nous accompagne concrètement et il ya
une volonté de réussir guillaume bigot
très rapidement s'il vous plaît la
question qu'on se pose est-ce qu'au
final c'est pas le consommateur qui va
qui va payer finalement soit par l'impôt
pour compenser les aides d'état soit par
tout simplement une augmentation des
prix dans les magasins dans les
restaurants et rapidement ben écoute et
non parce que le consommateur est
toujours un producteur né à la fois des
consommateurs et des producteurs
et quand vous dites qu'on va payer par
les prix je suis toujours un peu
sceptique sur la ils ont la théorie de
livrer chopin du libre marché mais ça ne
peut pas ça ne peut pas stimulé les
achats que d'élever des prix en résumé
il y à un choc qui est un choc extérieur
à l'économie et quels que soient les
efforts déployés par les commerçants il
a la solution ne peut venir que d'un
soutien une certaine façon artificielle
on venir compenser cette perte de
chiffre d'affaires et cette destruction
de trafic commercial
voilà s'il n'y a pas une aide massive et
c'est tout de suite qu'il faut cette
aide est ce que si elle n'est pas
maintenant ça va enclencher des
phénomènes qui seront irrécupérable en
clair les commerçants vont licencier ces
gens qui seront licenciés vont peser à
la baisse sur l'économie et tout ça va
avoir un effet de récessif
donc c'est maintenant qu'il faut agir
dit qu agir massivement le gouvernement
a bien fait avec le chômage partiel mais
c'est très insuffisant
merci à tous les deux français ce ballon
by française palombes et si vous
répondez vous à des attentats
guillaume bigot merci à vous et
également d'avoir été sur notre antenne
et un mot c'est qu'il faut aussi que se
responsabilise le consommateur nos
emplettes égale nos emplois merci et
voilà pour cette conclusion un petit mot
maintenant sur le bilan de l'épidémie
coronavirus dans l'hexagone on compte 28
mille deux cent quinze décès duo kobe 19
selon les chiffres de la direction
générale de la santé ce soir on compte
83 morts de plus lors des dernières 24
heures le nom de personnes en
réanimation continue de baisser avec 49
personnes de moins qu'hier
restez avec nous dans quelques instants
nous parlerons de l'espace schengen et
de son principe fondateur la suppression
des contrôles aux frontières intérieures
aujourd'hui largement ont remis en cause
par la menace sanitaire puis ce sera les
dites aux échos qui s'intéresse ce soir
la façon dont qu'ovide chamboulé
dell et économique
[Musique]
oui
nous allons évoquer ici des sujets
stratégiques pour notre pays et sur ces
dossiers sensibles
je vais partager avec vous une
interprétation la croissance des pays
émergents
la stagnation des pays occidentaux et le
ralentissement de ceux en développement
ont rendu la compétition économique
internationale
brut 1 soyons clairs dans la guerre
économique
tous les pousses ont terni la stratégie
de conquête de marchés à l'exportation
s'appuie sur une politique offensive de
pillage de fleurons du secteur
stratégique
le succès passe toujours par la
connaissance parfaite de son adversaire
en jouant sur quatre critères qui ai
l'argent
l'idéologie légaux et la compromission
ce phénomène il est mondial on le
retrouve partout
c'est pourquoi on est frappé par la
naïveté des personnels et d'encadrement
à ce type de prat une existe sur la
planète
beaucoup d'acteurs tchéquie et sans
aucune hésitation ni morale
la fin justifie les
[Musique]
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il arrive
quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du long vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
[Musique]
oui
merci à vous de nous rejoindre 20h30
heure française en direct sur rt france
le vieux continent et de casse tête
d'une éventuelle réouverture coordonnées
des frontières si la fermeture de
l'espace schengen a été très rapide la
levée progressive de ses réflexions se
fait en ordre dispersé chaque pays
jouant sa propre partition l'estonie la
lettonie ou encore la lituanie peu
touché par le coronavirus ont ouvert
leurs frontières le 5 mai dernier
ce sera le 3 juin pour l'italie la
france elle n'a pas encore donné de date
mais a cependant assoupli le passage
pour les travailleurs transfrontaliers
et pour en parler nous sommes avec
claude blanchemaison expert en relations
internationales bonsoir claude
blanchemaison merci d'être avec nous
alors les européens ont envie de voyager
évidemment cet été de profiter de
quelques jours de vacances comment
concilier la politique de tous ces pays
qui n'ont pas été impactées en faut le
rappeler de la même manière par par
cette crise
oui en effet des pays européens ont
réagi en ordre dispersé en fonction de
leur évaluation de la menace de l'état
de leur système sanitaire
et puis de la façon dont ils
appréhendaient les mouvements de
population avec l'extérieur
alors aujourd'hui on a en effet deux
deux systèmes qui ce qui coïncide d'une
part single mais géniale est un système
qui d'une part comporte des états qui ne
sont pas membres de la de l'union
européenne comme la norvège et la suède
et d'autre part certains états membres
de l'union européenne
le souk en manque de schengen comme par
exemple la roumanie ou la bulgarie alors
schengen c'est un système en fait qui
est touche à la frontière extérieure et
la frontières extérieures de schengen en
effet est tout à fait établi et pour se
protéger des à plus de personnes venant
venant de l'extérieur de cette de cette
zone les états membres quand ils sont
pris quand ils ont pris des mesures de
confinement quand ils ont pris des
mesures de restriction d'arrivée de
d'étrangers ont fait jouer
l'article 23 et l'article 28 de la
convention de schengen qui prévoit en
effet que en cas d'urgence sanitaire en
cas de situation extrêmement grave et
bien un état peut prendre des mesures
conservatoires et il peut fermer ses
frontières
il peut le faire pour un mois
renouvelable dans la limite de deux ans
ceci laisse du temps et j'espère bien
que les frontières sont ouvertes avant
et en deuxième lieu le système
communautaire l'union européenne dans
laquelle comme vous le savez la libre
circulation des personnes est un élément
essentiel comme la libre circulation des
biens et marchandises comme la libre
circulation des capitaux et là dessus
aussi
les états membres se sont mis en
exception compte tenu de l'état
d'urgence sanitaire et chacun a pris ces
mesures
naturellement en en parlant à la
commission et en se concertant aussi
possible avec ses voisins
pour ce qui est de la france président
de la république a dit lundi une fois de
plus très clairement que bien entendu il
faut rétablir la liberté de circulation
à l'intérieur de l'union européenne
bien entendu il faut rétablir la liberté
de circulation à l'intérieur de l'espace
schengen mais bien entendu dans le
respect d une réciprocité entre chacun
des états avec la france autrement dit
si l'italie maintien des restrictions
vis-à-vis de la france
eh bien la france maintiendra les mêmes
restrictions vis-à-vis de l'italie
si l'italie maintien si l'espagne
maintien des restrictions vide à vis de
la france
eh bien la france maintiendra les mêmes
restrictions vis-à-vis de l'espagne
pendant le temps où cela durera alors il
ya des négociations bilatérales en effet
avec tous ces pays il y en a eu avec
l'allemagne et ceci a déjà donné des
résultats puisque les travailleurs
frontaliers ont pu maintenance en
difficulté peuvent rejoindre leur
travail chaque jour
et effectivement je crois que la
concertation la plus forte se fait avec
l'allemagne mais elle se fait aussi par
les voies diplomatiques avec chacun des
autres états membres de l'union
européenne et de la zone schengen donc
progressivement au fur et à mesure que
la situation sanitaire s'améliorait et
bien d'ici quelques semaines au pire
quelques mois là
liberté de circulation à l'intérieur de
la zone schengen sera rétablie mais je
pense que les frontières extérieures
resteront fermés ou en tout cas très
surveillée pour longtemps alors au
club-house maison l'union européenne
semble sortir affaibli en cette crise du
coronavirus difficile effectivement de
son temps d'entre eux chefs d'état
parfois chaque pays va être impactée par
cette crise qu'on nous annonce
n'y at il pas un risque de repli sur soi
comment la solidarité européenne
peut-elle continuer d'exister
oui l'urgence sanitaire a fait que en
effet chaque pays s'est concentré sur
lui-même mais c'est dû au fait aussi que
les pères fondateurs de l'union
européenne ont très spécifiquement exclu
la santé du traité de rome et que leurs
successeurs dans tous les traités qu'on
peut avoir lieu masse riche lisbonne et
d'autres ont aussi exclu a santé par
conséquent la santé restent de la
compétence essentiellement national mais
comme ça a été dit par la chancelière et
par le président français lundi dernier
sans changer les traités
on peut faire un certain nombre de
choses ensemble on pourrait par exemple
avoir une agence commune d'évaluation de
la situation sanitaire
on pourra avoir des stocks communs
d'urgence en matière sanitaire de
produits médicaux et même de médicament
et puis surtout on peut financer en
commun la recherche pour trouver des
vaccins et des médicaments
alors pour le reste tous les états
membres constate aujourd'hui que le
confinement a fait la démonstration de
ce que l'on savait c'est à dire que si
on ferme les frontières
si en plus en même temps l'appareil
économique s'arrête et bien il ya une
formidable récession économique qui se
met en place
donc aujourd'hui ce qui est à l'ordre du
jour c'est la remise en marche des
appareils de production et d'appareils
de commerciaux nationaux mais aussi des
échanges à l'intérieur des états membres
parce que évidemment l'imbrication des
économies européennes fait que son
réouverture des frontières et bien
chaque pays perdrait un certain nombre
de ses clients de ses ses marchés il ya
donc urgence à faire repartir l'économie
et
c'est pour cela que en effet les états
membres de l'union européenne doivent
coordonner leurs mesures sur le plan
économique
merkel ont présenté un plan solidaire un
plan de relance à 500 milliards d'euros
je vous propose avant de le commenter
d'écouté de la chancelière allemande
nous voulons avoir un fonds qui soit
bien sûr limité dans le temps mais 500
milliards d'euros sont prévus il ne
s'agirait pas de crédit il s'agirait de
dépenses budgétaires qui serait
attribuée au secteur et aux régions les
plus touchées par l'aco vide
nous sommes convaincus que ces mesures
sont justifiées qu'elles sont
nécessaires
il est important que l'union européenne
mette de l'argent à disposition
et ça pendant plusieurs années il faudra
bien sûr rembourser cet argent
alors évidemment on retiendra comme
blanchemaison cette dernière phrase il
faudra rembourser cet argent c'est ce
que nous dit angela merkel sait ce qui
va pousser les européens à davantage de
solidarité entre eux oui parce que la
mécanique semble un peu complexe en
réalité elle est très simple elle
consiste à donner a eu à donner à
l'union européenne à travers la
commission la possibilité de lever sur
les marchés financiers 500 millions
d'euros pour financer ensuite par des
dotations budgétaires du budget européen
les régions et les secteurs peut-être là
des entreprises qui ont été les plus
impactés et puis ensuite les états
membres rembourseront à une échéance qui
reste à déterminer je pense que
l'emprunt sera fait à 10 ans au moins à
10 ans et que par conséquent c'est à cet
escient ce que se pose le problème du
remboursement et ce ne sont pas les
bénéficiaires entreprises aux régions de
députation budgétaire d'urgence décidée
par la commission
ils rembourseront ce sont les états
membres et ils rembourseront suivant une
clé qui reste à négocier et qui sera
très vraisemblablement très proche de la
clé budgétaires actuelles c'est-à-dire
pour l'allemagne la chancelière a cité
le chiffre de 27 % dans les faits entre
27 et 29 25 et 27% et pour la france
c'est aux environs de 17 à 18%
mais ceci reste à négocier puisque la
semaine prochaine
exactement
en banlieue dans une semaine la
commission doit faire une proposition
une proposition d'ensemble qui
comportera des précisions sur tous les
mécanismes et ya fort à parier que
probable qu'elle prendra en effet pour
une bonne partie les propositions franco
allemandes mais qu'elle y ajoutera
beaucoup de shows et il ya fort à parier
que à côté de ce qui doit faire l'objet
de dotation budgétaire donc de dons elle
mettra en place également des cités
système de prêt et c'est d'ailleurs le
apparemment le schéma sur lequel elle
travaillait surtout auparavant donc il
ya différents canaux par lesquels la
commission peut aussi envisager un
système de prêt aux régions et aux
secteurs les plus impactés par la crise
et ceci viendrait compléter le schéma
qui a été décidé par part décidé proposé
par la france et par l'allemagne
bien sûr reste à décider pour quels
montants pour l'un et pour l'autre
merci et bon claude blanchemaison pour
cet éclairage complet et on reste en
europe avec notamment l'espagne qui
poursuit son déconfinement depuis hier
les barcelonais peuvent à nouveau se
balader sur les plages le point sur la
situation espagnole avec quentin
mauclair sous un grand soleil
ces barcelonais retrouve les plages de
la mer méditerranée après plus de deux
mois d'interdiction si des sportives y
avait un accès restreint de 6h à 10h du
matin depuis une dizaine de jours ces
plages sont désormais ouverts toute la
journée
cependant la baignade reste proscrite
tout comme le bronzage et les sports
collectifs et la promenade doit se faire
obligatoirement en portant un masque des
restrictions loin d'être respectée ce
mercredi par des riverains qui ont des
difficultés à s'adapter à la situation
c'est ouf en mai nécessaire de porter ce
masque il faut l'utiliser mais il arrive
un moment où vous a été soufflé en fait
nous ne savions pas nous sommes venus
courir nous avions très chaud et nous
nous sommes baignés il y avait beaucoup
de monde sur la plage alors on s'est dit
pourquoi pas les autorités espagnoles
ont décrété que le port du masque sera
obligatoire dans tous les lieux publics
y compris dans la rue
si une distanciation de deux mètres est
impossible à respecter cette mesure
s'applique à toutes les personnes de 6
ans et plus le gouvernement souhaite
également prolongé l'état d'urgence
sanitaire
la prolongation de l'état d'urgence que
nous souhaitons et de 15 jours car le
développement de la pandémie nous oblige
à être plus dans l'état d'urgence doit
rester en vigueur tant qu'il est
nécessaire de restreindre partiellement
certains droits au nom de la santé
publique et pas un jour de plus je veux
demander pardon à nos concitoyens pour
les erreurs commises dans l'urgence en
raison de la pénurie de ressources du
caractère exceptionnel de cette crise et
de son ampleur comme de l'absence de
précédent mandat
et si pour 70% du pays la vie a repris
très prudemment son cours dans les
régions de madrid barcelone et de
castille leon des limitations plus
strictes demeure hier pedro sanchez a
donc présenté ses excuses aux espagnols
pour je cite les erreurs commises dans
l'urgence ces déclarations font suite
aux nombreuses manifestations qui ont eu
lieu dans le pays lundi pour demander sa
démission
je suis là pour exiger que monsieur
sanchez parc par skréla ruines de ce
pays
j'ai failli lui demander poliment de
partir qu'ils nous laissent qu'il
organise des élections et qu'ils
laissent les espagnols s'exprimer
cet homme est au pouvoir de façon
injustifiée qu'il parte
l'espagne compte plus de 27000 800 décès
depuis qu'a commencé la pandémie ce
mercredi le nombre de décès quotidiens
liés aux kovy 19 est resté en dessous
des 100 morts pour le quatrième jour
consécutif
la chute du tourisme et de l'aérien
contraintes sanitaires nouveaux modes de
consommation l'épidémie de coronavirus
bouleverse bon nombre de modèles
économiques
certains secteurs sont déjà au tpiy
alors que d'autres pourrait en sortir
renforcé alors question quels seront les
gagnants quels seront les perdants de
cette crise et avec quelles conséquences
économiques on voit cela tout de suite
avec vous jacques sapir que l'on
retrouve en duplex de nos studios de
caumartin bonsoir jacques alors square
stephenie à l'heure jacques cette crise
donc économique aura ses perdants et ses
gagnants comme chaque crise quelle
redistribution des cartes peut-on
s'attendre
oui c'est évident parce que cette crise
et on voit très bien qu'il ya trois
facteurs il ya évidemment le confinement
il y a après l'arrêt des transports
et puis il y aussi la crainte d'un
redémarrage justement de cette élite
tout ceci a un impact extrêmement
important sur l'activité économique
alors oui il va y avoir malheureusement
des perdants pense au tourisme mais n'y
pas eu il ya l'automobile il ya aussi un
secteur à haute technologie comme le
secteur aérien à la fois en transport et
en industrie aérospatiale et puis d'un
autre côté il y aura très probablement
des gagnants comme le secteur de
l'économie de la santé mais aussi
l'ensemble du commerce électronique ce
qu'on appelle le e-commerce voir
d'autres secteurs alors jacques
commençons par les perdants vous avez
cité le tourisme qu'on est il alors oui
c'est évident le tourisme qui est un
secteur économique important
un kit pèse d'ailleurs en france va être
très touché par la crise vous savez le
tourisme ça représente à peu de choses
près 7 points du pib 7% du pib mais un
peu plus de 10% de l'emploi privé donc
on voit bien que c'est un secteur
important et malheureusement on sait que
ce secteur va souffrir de la crise
jacquard en raison des mesures de
protection et des restrictions
d'ouverture des restaurants
les plages oui oui stéphanie c'est
évident mais il n'y a que ça vous savez
la france est une destination
touristique importante elle recevait
tous les ans à peu près 90 millions de
touristes étrangers
or cette année en mettant les choses au
mieux on devrait être à 20 millions de
touristes étrangers
qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça veut dire
qu'il va y avoir une baisse importante
de clientèle dans toute une série de
choses que l'on visite alors ça peut
être évidemment le parc disneyland mais
c'est quand même aussi le château de
versailles
c'est la tour eiffel près derrière ces
grands lieux que l'on visite
qu'est ce qu'il y a il ya quand même des
entités alors qu'elles soient privées
comme disneyland qu'elle soit publique
l'établissement du louvre par exemple et
ses entités
eh bien elle emploie des milliers de
gens prenez par exemple vous avez le puy
du fou 2000 salariés donc tout ceci fait
que le choc lié à l'absence des
touristes étrangers va être très
durement ressentie et si on ajoute à ça
évidemment l'impact sur l'hôtellerie sur
la restauration qui au mieux ne
repartira qu'à moitié voire aux deux
tiers de sa capacité
on voit qu'il va y avoir une perte
d'emploi importantes dans tous les
emplois saisonniers qui était justement
l'une des bases essentielles de
l'activité dans ce secteur
par ailleurs il faut ajouter que est un
autre secteur qui va être très touché
c'est la restauration d'entreprise parce
que beaucoup d'entreprises vont rester
en télétravail t'es pas totalement mais
vos récents parquet en télétravail et
cela bien entendu aura comme conséquence
une baisse de l'activité de l'ensemble
des entreprises de la restauration
collective
alors vous nous dites aussi jacques ce
phénomène va toucher des secteurs à
haute technologie wii est le premier
secteur c'est évidemment le secteur de
l'aéronautique alors pourquoi il faut
savoir que d'abord cette crise elle a un
impact immédiat sur le transport aérien
or le transport aérien c'est quoi
c'était grosso modo 160 millions de
voyageurs qui partait de la france des
français des étrangers qui rentrait
c'est une ou deux bons mais voilà il ya
un nombre de voyageurs extrêmement
important or là aussi on peut s'attendre
à une baisse de 50% voire plus
qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça veut dire
que certaines compagnies aériennes vont
faire faillite des petites ou des
compagnies aériennes de taille moyenne
donc tout le secteur on appelle le
secteur du low cost et bien c'est le
modèle général le modèle économique de
ce secteur qui est remis en cause parce
que faire du low cost
si vous maintenez la distanciation
physique dans les avions ça va être très
très très difficile or qu'est ce que ça
implique et bien ça implique évidemment
une moindre demande d'avions la demande
d'avions va baisser
il ya toute une série de commandes qui
vont être annulées et évidemment savoir
un ça va avoir un impact sur la
construction mais aussi et c'est très
important sur l'ensemble des
sous-traitants de ce secteur
jacques et c est précisément un secteur
où la place de la france était plutôt on
peut le dire traditionnellement forte
oui elle était traditionnellement forte
elle est toujours traditionnellement
forte
si vous voulez mais il faut aussi
comprendre une chose c'est que c'est un
secteur qui est géographiquement très
concentré pour dire les choses un petit
peu rapidement c'est ce qu'on appelle le
grand sud ouest et dans ce grand sud
ouest et bien vous voyez on a environ
160 mille travailleurs qui sont dans ce
secteur dont 122 milles directement or
malheureusement on peut penser qu'il y
aura entre un cas où un tiers de mise en
forme de mise au chômage
donc vous voyez bien il va y avoir une
perte d'emploi importantes et cette
perte d'emploi aura un effet boule de
neige sur toute une série d'autres
emplois alors par ailleurs il faut aussi
évidemment dire une chose c'est que ça
va entraîner une forme de
restructuration
pour l'instant le secteur de la
construction aérospatiale et est portée
essentiellement par des activités
civiles des activités privées
désormais ce seront plutôt des activités
militaires qui vont donner le ton qui
vont donner le la à ce secteur et donc
il va y avoir là un vrai problème pour
chercher à éviter qu'une partie de ces
emplois qui risquent d'être perdus ne le
soit pas pourquoi parce que on est en
présence de travailleurs dont les
compétences sont
extrêmement spécialisé jacques est ce
que ce sont les seules victimes et seuls
qui vont souffrir
hélas non hélas non on sait qu'il y aura
d'autres secteurs qui vont être affectés
en particulier évidemment le secteur de
l'automobile mais aussi c'est un point
important le secteur de la grande
distribution est d'ores et déjà on voit
qu'il ya un certain nombre de grandes
enseignes qui soit sont en faillite
choix sont en grande difficulté alors
jacques vous nous aviez promis quand
même y aurait également des gagnants oui
tout à fait et je voudrais aussi apporté
là peut-être une petite pointe
d'optimisme alors il y aura des gagnants
dans trois secteurs
premier secteur c'est évidemment toute
l'économie de la santé ça va de la
pharmacie la parapharmacie évidemment
par exemple et parce que les tests etc
mais aussi l'industrie du logiciel et
logiciel de diagnostic à distance pour
tout ce secteur va connaître une demande
très fort et va connaître à l'évidence
un soutien important de l'état tant que
là il est clair que ce secteur il va
plutôt recruter et embaucher un deuxième
secteur qui va connaître un
développement important
c'est évidemment ce qu'on appelle le
e-commerce on voit bien et ça a déjà
commencé pendant le confinant que toutes
les grandes sociétés de e-commerce et
bien elles tirent mieux leur épingle du
jeu que le commerce traditionnel
et puis il ya un troisième secteur et ça
c'est un petit peu plus étonnant mais
c'est intéressant c'est le secteur de
l'agroalimentaire c'est le secteur de
l'alimentation pourquoi parce que au
travers du confinant au travers de cette
crise eh bien il semble que les français
il est retrouvé le goût de manger
français ou en tous les cas d'avoir
recours plutôt à des productions locales
et tout ceci bien sûr ça un coup ça veut
dire que on accepte de payer un peu plus
cher les produits mais ça va très
certainement renforcer l'agriculture et
l'ensemble du secteur agroalimentaire
qui va avec
alors jacques en conclusion qu'est ce
que cela implique-t-il pour l'économie
eh bien première chose qu'il faut dire
c'est que cette crise c'est pas
simplement un choc économique
c'est une véritable transformation il y
à des secteurs qui vont se rétracter qui
vont dépérir et pour plusieurs années
peut-être une dizaine d'années c'est une
évidence d'autres secteurs qui vont
connaître comme je viens de vous
l'expliquer un développement extrêmement
important donc ça c'est le premier point
le deuxième point et qui me semble
important c'est que malheureusement
entre les secteurs que j'appelle un
petit peu rapidement lesecteur perdants
et les secteurs gagnants
eh bien il n'y a pas égalité en matière
d'emploi et ça pose un véritable
problème
il va falloir trouver des emplois pour
tous ces personnels qui vont être
licenciés dans le secteur du tourisme de
la restauration mais aussi tous et tous
ces travailleurs qui risquent de perdre
leur emploi par exemple dont
l'automobile ou dans l'aéronautique est
mais ça m'amène à une troisième
contestation c'est le fait que
évidemment et et bien la volonté de
maintenir un certain nombre d'emplois ne
serait ce que pour que à savoir faire ne
se perdent pas eh bien ça va entraîner
une intervention qu'elle soit directe ou
moins directe de l'état
de plus en plus importante dans
l'économie eh bien merci jacques canteau
ses explications éclairante sur ce qui
nous est un merci à vous elle reste avec
nous dans quelques instants nous
reviendrons sur le pont de l'ascension
et les craintes de la part des autorités
d'un relâchement des français prudence
respect des gestes barrières et dans la
limite des 100 km le gouvernement veille
au grain et puis nous parlerons d'air
france la compagnie nationale qui
annonce l'arrêt définitif
l'exploitation de ses airbus a380
deux ans et demi avant la date prévue
nouveau coup dur
[Musique]
dans ce contexte de crise sanitaire
mondiale quel rôle doivent selon vos
jouets à lévis mais quel rôle
joue-t-elle dans les faits les villes
tout comme les états ils n'étaient pas
préparés
c'est là mais les villes elles se sont
connectés tout de suite entre elles pour
voir comment elles pouvaient coopérer
il ya eu l'envoi des beaucoup de des
masques de matériels médicaux d'une
commune à l'autre selon vous à quoi
pourront ressembler les îles comment
est-ce qu'elles vont se transformer
après la pandémie la crise maintenant à
fait bien comprendre qu'on peut pas
s'oublier des banlieues on peut pas
oublier les quartiers pauvres parce que
véritablement être en partie de la vie
donc les grandes villes quand il se
connecte n est pas seulement d'elle même
elle parle aussi de comment caissettes
cercle vertueux avec les villes des
alentours
[Musique]
le virus agit plus sur les poumons sur
le cerveau si j'ai bien compris et donc
ça me paraît difficile d'imaginer un
monde totalement différent la pandémie
va pas avoir changé fondamentalement les
règles du jeu et les règles de la vie
quotidienne selon patrick artus la crise
du collègue 19 pourrait sonner le glas
du capitalisme néolibéral c'est un choc
exogène c'est quelque chose qui est
arrivé de l'extérieur et qui traduit pas
une défaillance du système économique
capitaliste mondialisé marocaine vivant
le virus a servi de catalyseur
mais les problèmes étaient déjà là les
problèmes de gilet jaune ça date pas de
du virus
[Musique]
vous parlez de résilience comment est-ce
qu'on pourrait le définir
c'est après un traumatisme qu'est ce
qu'on fait combien on reste traumatisée
bien on cherche en soi et autour de
soins quels sont les facteurs qui vont
nous permettre de reprendre un nouveau
développement et d'un fonds talents de
résilience la catastrophe économique
dont on parle
elle est liée directement au confinement
c'est à dire à la mise en coma
artificiel de l'économie catastrophe ça
veut dire à côté
cata strophe là il ya un tournant et on
se remet à vivre mais dans une autre
direction
c'est la première fois dans l'histoire
de l'humanité que pour sauver des vies
humaines en ruines la moitié de la
planète
jamais on a fait simple jamais plaint
d'une décision invraisemblable pour vous
ça dépend telles valeurs on attribuait
la mort la vie humaine
si on considère que la vie humaine est
plus précieuse que l'économie on a bien
fait mais si on considère que maintenant
il va y avoir des catastrophes humaines
individuelles avec cette décision
alors je sais pas c'est un débat n'aura
un débat éthique
certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes mais vous
[Musique]
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons la
liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes cette diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même on
va parler évidemment de l'impact
économique de cette pandémie est ce que
tous les pays africains vont être
impactés continuant va revoir vraiment
une de ses pires années de 70 dernière
même si les conséquences seront
différentes selon les pays
nous avons là une situation où pour
sauver les économies africaines il va
falloir créer de l'activité il faut de
l'argent pour pouvoir se tirer
d'affaires pendant cette année 73
millions de personnes touchées quand
même par le crise alimentaire dans
quelle mesure cette pandémie du colis de
19 risque d'aggraver les choses ça c'est
la troisième crise la part la solitaire
est hélas la crise économique nous
allons avoir une crise de sécurité
alimentaire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
est ce qu'on sait combien d'enfants sont
victimes de ces violences et qui sont
concernés par ces drames qui se déroule
dans le huis clos familial pendant la
période actuelle il est difficile de
dire précisément combien d'enfants sont
concernés car en fait on a très peu de
visibilité
nous savons simplement que il y à des
situations effectivement qui s'aggrave
dans les familles il ya toutes les
classes sociales qui sont concernés par
la maltraitance il faut qu'on le lise
ils redisent là le problème c'est que
dans le cas du confinement il n'y a plus
cet entourage et tout se fait à distance
ce qui fait qu'il est très difficile de
repérer par téléphone par visiophone ces
situations et notre inquiétude elles
portent plutôt sur ce que nous voyons
pas la partie immergée de l'iceberg en
fait parce que les très difficile pour
les enfants malgré tout d'après eux
mêmes et dans ce cas là on n'entend rien
ça se fait totalement dans le silence
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous merci nous rejoindre pour
cette deuxième heure d'information il
est 21h heure de paris tout de suite
voici les titres de l'actualité de ce
jeudi 21 mai en france en week-end
prolongé et des inquiétudes les
autorités redoutent un afflux de
promeneurs ils pourraient favoriser une
flambée de l'épidémie
les contrôles des forces de l'ordre sont
donc renforcé sur le plan politique et
loire philippe doit se prononcer d'ici à
samedi sur la tenue du second tour des
municipales
au revoir l'a380 alors que le secteur
aérien est en pleine crise air france a
choisi d'accélérer la fin d'exploitation
du plus gros porteur commercial d'airbus
une décision à effet immédiat qui
n'aurait dû arriver qu'en 2022 en échec
commercial pour ce géant des airs jugé
trop cher pas assez rentable et trop
polluants le bras de fer entre la chine
et les etats unis se poursuit pékin
menace de rétorsions en cas de sanctions
américaines et réfute les propos de
donald trump nos présidents américains
accusent pékin d'une tuerie de masse
mondial à cause du coronavirus donald
trump qui menacent de rompre toute
relation plus de 93 mille personnes sont
lors du coc vide 19
aux etats unis ces pays le plus touché
au monde
en amérique latine jusqu'ici
relativement épargnée les contaminations
augmente de façon inquiétante le brésil
troisième foyer de contamination dans le
monde approche les 1000 décès en 24
heures et atteint plus de 19000 mort
face à ces chiffres le ministère
brésilien de la santé générale il lusage
de l'hydroxyde chloroquine
[Musique]
et un mot tout d'abord sur le bilan de
l'épidémie coronavirus dans l'hexagone
on compte 28 mille deux cent quinze
décès dus aux convives selon les
chiffres de la direction générale de la
santé 83 morts de plus lors des 24
dernières heures le nombre de personnes
en réanimation continue lui aussi baissé
avec 49 personnes de moins et qui hier
le week-end prolongé de l'ascension est
tout de même surveiller de très près
quatre jours ensoleillés qui font
craindre un afflux de promeneurs avec un
risque de relancer l'épidémie olivier
ferrand se veut extrêmement vigilants
les contrôles devraient être nombreux
pour faire respecter la limite des
fameux son km autour de son domicile à
paris
nombreux étaient ceux à profiter du beau
temps sur les quais de seine écouter ces
quelques réactions je pense que le
risque zéro n'existe pas et il sera
toujours présent sur ces deux voire
trois prochains mois c'est sûr et
certain
maintenant j'ai confiance au
gouvernement et sur leur capacité à
réguler
les métros etc j'ai confiance au
gouvernement mais
on n'a pas eu encore les résultats donc
il faut être prudent a minima ce week
end
oui j'ai un masque dans le métro mais ça
s'arrête là j'ai réagi à l'hydraulique
maintenant voilà on est sur les quais on
n'est pas plus de 10 sont se rassemblent
pas trop non non ça s'arrête les les
gestes barrière classique
je me dis qu'il faut bien vivre avec
elle je pense que là les gens quand même
été assez sensibilisés avec le
confinement et je trouve que les gens
respectent plutôt assez bien que se soit
dans les lieux publiques style
supermarchés etc
donc j'ai une petite crainte mais disons
que bon bah bien falloir vivre avec
donc je trouve que les gens sont quand
même assez respectueux des textes des
gestes barrières
bon on a remis on s'est remis à voir
quelques copains mais pour l'instant
c'était des apéros à 10,10 on est des
couples qui respecterait les règles
normalement donc le risque un peu après
c'est vrai que bon bah pour les
personnes plus âgées par exemple ma mère
qui est à 70 ans
bon ben voilà j'essaie des précautions
je fais attention et c'est après nous on
n'est pas une population à risque non
plus donc on continue à respecter les
règles et bien sûr ah ouais bon après
voilà je vois mes amis mais je leur fais
confiance
mais moi je suis dans la rue et tout
j'essaie de m'éloigner au max dans le
métro j'ai le mass medias obligatoire et
ah oui non je reste pas à côté des gens
c'est pas très gentil et du coup mais il
faut faire voilà et puis à le gel
hydraulique ça y va on y va on la jette
tout méfait ne vais pas grave on fait
plus attention forcée
pour en parler nous sommes avec
catherine hill épidémiologiste bonsoir
madame il merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france voulait tout
d'abord vous faire réagir sur ces
voix-là ses interviews de jeunes qui
sont plutôt confiants à ces philosophes
assez serein finalement vous ça vous
inquiète les entendre comme ça ils sont
dans la rue ils voient des amis avec pas
mal de confiance tout en respectant tout
même les gestes barrière oui ils sont
jeunes et ils n'ont pas l'air de te
rends tu compte que six rencontres le
virus ils peuvent rester asymptomatique
et le rapporter à la maison est
contaminé par exemple leurs parents qui
sont plus âgés
donc je pense que il devrait avoir des
masques quand ils sont dehors même
simplement sur les quais par exemple
personne très peu de gens ont des
masques et ça c'est vraiment pas bien du
tout il faut pas seulement mettre des
masses dans le métro c'est vrai qu'on a
un plus grand risque de se contaminer
dans le métro mais le confie mme de
déconfinement fait que les gens vont
croiser plus de personnes qu auparavant
et dont qu'ils augmentent leur risque de
rencontrer le virus il faut bien
comprendre que la moitié des
contaminations viennent de personnes qui
ne savent pas contaminée qui n'ont pas
de symptômes
soit parce qu'elles n'en n'ont pas et
n'auront jamais soit parce qu'elles
n'ont pas encore donc la moitié des
contaminations
petit problème de liaison avec catherine
hill je ne sais pas si on va avoir la
chance de récupérer notre invité non on
me dit plus tard d'un petit point de
deux réseaux y est on va passer au
personnel soignant qui eux ne relâche
pas la pression sur le gouvernement
illustration à l'hôpital robert debré à
paris cet après midi devant lequel un
rassemblement ait lieu pour demander
davantage de moyens et de reconnaissance
malgré les promesses du ministre de la
santé sur deux meilleurs salaires notre
reporter d'al jaber asa qui étaient sur
place
pas de médaille mais des moyens
financiers supplémentaires voilà ce que
réclame le personnel de l'hôpital robert
debré à paris qui s'est réuni devant
l'établissement pour la deuxième fois en
une semaine
ces soignants réclamé plus d'effectifs
plus de lits des augmentations de
salaires et des conditions de travail
meilleures en sommes membres
d'associations chez les jeunes et
personnalités politiques ont participé à
cette manifestation aujourd'hui je vous
propose d'en écouter quelques cents ça
fait déjà plus d'un an que les soignants
et soignante était mobilisée et
expliquer justement que c'était
intenable
la seule raison pour laquelle on a
réussi à assurer une réponse sanitaire
c'est parce que elle et ils ont donné un
plus que plus que humainement possible
il s'agit pas juste de distribuer des
primes au lance-pierre à tel ou un tel
il faut revaloriser l'ensemble
l'ensemble des salaires dans l'ensemble
de la santé et du médico-social et a
changé comme ils le demandent
là le mode d'organisation des hôpitaux
pour plus de démocratie doit on
manifeste pour faire entendre notre voix
parce que pour l'instant on entend
surtout la voix du gouvernement qui est
en train de faire une communication
comme quoi tout a été formidable et
nous on est là pour dire que tout n'a
pas été formidable loin de là il parle
d'augmentation de salaires mais sous
conditions ça va être du travailler plus
pour gagner plus c'est sait déjà ce pour
faire tard c'est vrai que taper dans les
mains au stade c'est bien mais j'ose
espérer que les citoyens et citoyennes
ne vont pas s'arrêter là ils vont
réellement prendre position une
manifestation qui avait bien commencé
mais qui s'est terminée par quelques
tensions
une vingtaine de manifestants ont été
menacés par les forces de l'ordre et
ensuite verbaliser 135 euros damende
pour participation à une manifestation
non autorisée et on va retourner voir
notre épidémiologistes madame catherine
hill la connexion normalement a été
récupéré on est ravi de vous revoir
madame il alors vous nous expliquer un
petit peu vos craintes un de ces jeunes
qui sont entassés sur les quais son
masque puisque vous disiez que pour vous
le plus dangereux c'était les
asymptomatiques qui risquait donc de
contaminer les personnes les plus
fragiles peut-être chez eux alors la
question suivante c'est justement ce
week end de l'ascension pour vous est ce
que c'est ce type de week-end qui est le
week end de tous les dangers il fait
beau les gens sont dehors avec notamment
des parcs fermés à paris est ce que
c'est un danger
ça suffit d inquiétude selon vous mais
les gens se déplacent et ils vont
rencontrer des personnes qui ne
rencontre pas d'habitude surtout qu'ils
n'ont pas rencontré pendant qu'ils ont
été confinés donc si vous rencontrez
plus de gens vous avez plus de chance de
tomber sur le virus c'est juste
mathématiques c'est bête mais ça marche
et le virus est partout dans le pays on
voit bien alors on a tous ces foyers
quand là qu'on détecte parce que
maintenant quand on trouve un cas
symptomatique
on teste les gens autour et évidemment
quand autour d'un cap positif
il ya d'autres cas c'est tellement
obligatoire c'est la caractéristique de
la maladie contagieuse donc plus et j'en
rencontre d'autres gens ses amis qui ne
se sont pas vus depuis longtemps qui se
retrouvent ils augmentent leurs chances
de tomber sur le virus et et la personne
en qui ils ont confiance peut avoir été
contaminées allez on
pour le moment évidemment on reste
prudents sont plutôt rassurants mais
vous allez me dire certainement que ce
ne sont pas les vrais chiffres liés aux
premiers effets du déconfinement pour
cela il va falloir patienter jusqu'à la
semaine prochaine pour reconnaître les
les premiers effets justement oui bien
sûr les hospitalisations arrive
peut-être huit ou dix jours après la
contamination
les entrées en réanimation arrive encore
après et les morts encore plus tard donc
on a des indicateurs qui sont très
retardé on est en train de voir les
effets du confinement mais on voit pas
les effets du déconfinement il faudra un
peu de temps pour vous de voir
alors à quel à partir de quel seuil on
pourrait parler de deuxième vague selon
vous quel est le chiffre encore entre
guillemets acceptable pour un médecin
c'est très simple en ce moment il ya
encore cinq mille personnes en
réanimation dans le pays ce qui est
énorme
si on ajoute un peu moins de 2000 pour
coville 19 il ya aussi tous les autres
qui sont en réanimation parce qu'on les
a opéré et qu'ils ont besoin d'être en
réanimation pour d'autres raisons
donc on nous a dit qu'il y avait 5000
places en tout et il ya encore cinq
mille personnes en réanimation et en
plus et sont pas répartis également dans
le pays elles sont surtout en ile de
france et probablement aussi dans le
grand est est un peu dans le nord donc
la situation encore extraordinairement
tendue par exemple en ile de france ou
dans de grotesques donc il ya un
problème là et donc des 6 un repas un
peu ça va devenir insupportable pour les
services médicaux qui soutenait
hospitaliers qui ont déjà été très
saturé pendant des semaines et des
semaines
alors on le voit la france dé confine
pas que d'ailleurs la france dans les
autres pays européens on parle de l'art
ouverture des frontières les magasins
rouvrent également
c'était une mauvaise stratégie selon
vous on va peut-être trop vite ou le
respect des gestes barrière pourrait
suffire à contenir l'épidémie
moi je pense que pour contenir
l'épidémie il faut chercher beaucoup
plus systématiquement les gens qui sont
positifs et pas testé seulement les
symptomatique et leurs contacts mais
tester l'ensemble de la population
il n'y a que comme ça qu'on arrivera à
contrôler cette épidémie dans les pays
où on a testé très largement la
l'épidémie a été très bien contrôlé à
taïwan 24 millions d'habitants sept mois
et donc ils savent très bien géré la
chose et c'est la règle c'est tester
tester tester donc il faut tester
beaucoup plus largement la population et
on peut faire des tests groupe et on
peut rassembler les prélèvements de 20
personnes les rechercher les virus dans
un tube dans lequel on a mis les
prélèvements de 20 personnes si c'est
négatif les vingt personnes sont
négatives c'est quand même assez
efficace tu en as morgan intel je me
permets de vous couper parce que c'est
vrai que les citoyens nous sommes on est
parfois un petit peu perdu avec ces
tests
on a tous autour de nous des gens qui
ont fait des tests et qui sont
curieusement négatif alors qu'ils
avaient tous les symptômes est ce que
c'était ce sont véritablement fille a
aujourd'hui aucun test n'est parfait
mais si vous enlevez déjà sept positifs
qui contamine autour de lui sur 10 vous
avez déjà beaucoup gagné
donc le fait que ça soit pas parfait
n'est pas une raison pour ne pas le
faire aucun test diagnostic n'est
absolument parfait il ya toujours des
faux négatifs et qu'elle voit aussi des
faux bond positive dont c'est pas du
tout une raison pour ne pas tester
aujourd'hui quand vous entendez le
professeur raoul tu as un marseillais
qui fait beaucoup parler de lui qui dit
que selon lui l'épidémie va s'évanouir
alors il ne dit pas que la circulation
du virus va s'arrêter mais que
l'épidémie va sivan nuit sous va
s'évanouir que les courbes restent
plutôt basse vous le trouvez
irresponsable
de parler ainsi il a aussi dit que ça
allait être une petite gripette c'est
pas vraiment une petite grippe on
s'entre tuer quand même des quantités de
jean la place sur la planète entière
donc il n'a pas fait preuve il n'était
pas très éclairé ce jour-là donc
maintenant il nous montre les courbes
qui sont les faits du confinement qui a
diminué mais maintenant les contacts
entre les gens augmentent donc forcément
le risque var et augmenté et on peut pas
dire que les gens respectent les
règlements barrière admirablement tout
le monde devrait porter des masques
quand même d'or et tous les personnes
que vous avez interviewé n'avait pas de
masque c'est vrai oui je sais bien et et
du gouvernement un pathogène sur le
sujet des masques d'une façon absolument
colossal donc qu'est-ce que je peux je
pourrais vous dire les pays où on la
recommande l usage du masque ont quand
même beaucoup moins un problème donc
c'est évidemment ça qu'il fallait faire
maintenant il ya des masses qu'il
faudrait changer comme discours soient
claires mais les discours a toujours
aussi cafouilleux donc je pense qu'il
faut porter un masque
dès qu'on sort pas de chez soi encore
plus si on rentre dans un endroit fermé
à magasins etc mais aussi dehors parce
que on peut rencontrer des gens qui
parlent qui crache et le virus que
arrivée sur votre figure donc porter des
masques
mercereau on restera sur ce conseil
catherine hill merci d'avoir été avec
nous en direct sur rt france le reste de
l'actualité marquée également par des
tensions dans les quartiers réputés
difficiles depuis quatre nuits des
heurts ont éclaté entre habitants et
forces de l'ordre à argenteuil dans le
val d'oise ces violences font suite à la
mort d'un jeune motard de 18 ans le
week-end dernier elle les circonstances
restent encore floues dix personnes ont
été interpellées plusieurs véhicules et
plusieurs poubelles ont été incendiées
le calme est revenu vers 2 heures du
matin aucun blessé à signaler
et pour rendre hommage à ce jeune motard
de 18 ans une marche blanche s'est tenue
à argenteuil cet après midi notre
reporter david khalifa était sur place
après le temps du choc et de la douleur
puis de la colère et des incidents qu'il
ya eu encore la nuit dernière
en taule place au recueillement et au
calme pour cette marche blanche
organisée à l'initiative de la famille
de ce jeune motard de 18 ans à sabri
morts le week end dernier dans un
accident de moto et dont les
circonstances restent encore flous de
nombreuses personnes ont répondu
présentes pour honorer la mémoire de
sabri tous avaient un t-shirt avec
l'inscription lumière pour sabri puisque
effectivement cette marche blanche était
avant tout pour honorer la mémoire de ce
jeune motard de 18 ans mais également
pour dénoncer l'aggravation des
violences policières qui il y aurait eu
durant le confinement dans les banlieues
omar slaouti l'organisateur de cette
marche blanche chez nous explique
pourquoi cette marche blanche jalaa
symbole particulier c'est un hommage
profond où il y aura un mélange de
larmes d'émotion dépenser à l'endroit de
sabri qui nous a quittés à l'âge de 18
ans
c'est pas pour rien c'est une initiative
qui vient des amis de sabri d'abord
évidemment qui a été porté par la
famille les parents premier lieu sa
soeur donc il y aurait une banderole de
tête avec eux devant et tous et toutes
celles qui veulent se recueillir à
l'endroit de sabri et ce sera donc de
fait une marche silencieuse sans slogan
ça ne veut pas dire qu'il ya pas de
colère à l'intérieur qui a pas
d'amertume cas pas des goûts qui a pas
de sentiment d'injustice mais là en
l'occurrence ça va être un moment où on
va se poser entre nous le cortège s'est
élancé du lieu de départ où a eu lieu
l'accident jusqu'au aux poteaux ou et
lieu le drame qui se trouve juste
derrière moi de nombreuses personnalités
politiques ont également pris part à ce
cortège pour apporter leur soutien et
leur solidarité à la famille et aux
proches de la victime
ça fait beaucoup aujourd'hui beaucoup de
jeunes qui meurent en croisant
le chemin de la police donc sa famille
demande la justice et la vérité sur ce
qui s'est passé donc on va être dans le
recueillement et le travail de
revendications sur la vérité la justice
sur ce qui s'est passé ça viendra dans
un second temps et en tous cas c'était
normal de venir
moi j'habite saint denis on est à côté
mais ça aurait pu être un gamin de saint
denis il avait 18 ans donc ça peut être
n'importe quel gamin demain qui par
malchance se croiser la route de la
police et décède j'ai aussi entendu a
tout de suite là le début du cortège des
gens qui disaient dans la joie dans la
bonne humeur c'est c'est aussi j'imagine
en mémoire du jeune sabri voilà venir
marcher pour lui pour son souvenir et
puis évidemment contester un voile à se
battre aussi pour ça ne se reproduise
plus et ce qui n'allait pas y avoir une
enquête et on va savoir si c'est passé
mais actuellement il ya un rapport à la
police qui est compliqué dans les
quartiers populaires il faut il faut que
ce sera pour la i ly cesse quoi beaucoup
de tristesse et beaucoup d'émotion
devant ce poteau qui se trouve derrière
moi une minute de silence a été
respectée suivie d'une minute
d'applaudissements à savoir que toutes
les mesures d'hygiène ont été respectées
à la lettre également le port du masque
et la distanciation social était de mise
1 pour que cette marche blanche ait lieu
cet après midi à argenteuil
autre point à signaler elle est la
lumière qu'il faut faire autour de cet
accident puisque une enquête a été
ouverte par le parquet de son côté la
famille du jeune sabri a porté plainte
la fin d'une époque air france arrête
l'exploitation de l'airbus a380 jugées
trop chères et peu rentable son mari
était prévue en 2022 déjà cloué au sol
les neuf avions de la compagnie
n'effectue rend plus de vols commerciaux
air france expliqué que l'avion
consommer trop de kérosène pour la
compagnie aérienne ce retrait s'inscrit
dans une politique de simplification de
la flotte pour en parler nous sommes
avec michel polacco journaliste
spécialisé dans l'aéronautique et
l'aviation auteurs de l' aventure à 380
ch est bon soir michel polacco merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur rt francs
parce que cet arrêt soudain de l'a380
est ce que c'est une surprise pour vous
la faute là encore encore d'un virus en
fait l'a380 c'était un pari assez
dangereux assez risqué qui a été fait
par jean luc lagardère
au début des années 2000 un avion
capable d'emporter 853 passagers +1
membres d'équipage donc un avion qui
était fait pour une conception du
transport aérien qui consistait à
alimenter des centres de correspondances
avec des petits avions et ensuite à
relier les grands centres de
correspondance dans le monde c'est à
dire en gros 80 aéroports
en fait les choses ne sont pas du tout
passé comme ça dès le départ et dès le
départ on a décidé pour faciliter la vie
des passagers qui trouvait ça agréable
du d'effectuer beaucoup de lignes
directes de pointe à point on appelle ça
par exemple aller de bordeaux à toronto
etc
c'est à dire partir de villes
secondaires ou tertiaires pour aller
vers d'autres villes secondaires ou
tertiaires donc déjà l'a380 n'a pas
trouvé sa place dans cet univers
sachant qu aucune compagnie ne l'a
exploité avec 853 passagers au mieux
c'était 615 pour la compagnie emirates
est généralement entre 450 et 550 pour
des compagnies comme singapour qantas
lufthansa ou air france donc c'est un
avion qui n'a jamais été exploitée dans
les conditions où il était vraiment
économique
enfin et avec le virus qui est arrivé
est la réduction très probables
d'environ 40 à 50% du nombre de
passagers tous les gros porteurs vont
être sanctionnés
y compris les boeing 777 que certaines
compagnies américaines comme delta
airlines ont décidé de remiser
évidemment l'a380 va être très
sévèrement punis alors on s'en souvient
un petit peu d'herbe la guéguerre à
l'époque entre le 747 le mythique 747 et
sept a380
sauf erreur de ma part je me souviens
que ce 380 était plutôt présenté comme
celui qui était rentable celui qui
allait faire économiser par rapport aux
747 colons expliqué quand même c'est cet
échec commercial cuisant auquel on ne
s'attendait pas nécessairement
effectivement elle est pas encore ont
salué une prouesse de mémoire
effectivement lorsque l'airbus 380 été
lancée le boeing 747 était en fin de vie
il était vieux fatigués usés il avait 40
ans passés et donc on pouvait penser que
l'a380 allait prendre sa place est allé
remporter un gros marché
d'un autre côté boeing avec le boeing
747 tenait le marché des très gros
porteurs et à ce titre faisait les
tarifs de l'aviation commerciale dans le
monde comme il ya deux constructeurs
dans le monde aujourd'hui
airbus et boeing il est bien évident que
boeing avait une sorte de monopole et
faisait les tarifs et avec l'a380 airbus
voulait lui casser son monopole ce qui
est ce qui s'est produit c'est ce que je
vous ai un peu expliqué tout à l'heure
et qui évidemment était très défavorable
à l'a380
c'est qu'à l'époque on disait le ciel
est trop encombré les aéroports sont
trop encombrer les avions consomme trop
de carburant
on va faire un avion moderne qui emmène
beaucoup beaucoup de passagers faut pas
oublier que l'airbus 380 avec 853
passagers
c'était 2 litres aux cent c'est à dire
très très peu mais voilà il se trouve
que on a préféré garder le ciel encombré
on a préféré continuer encombrer les
aéroports et on a préféré continuer à
utiliser des avions de taille plus
petite mais la sanction la pire elle
arrive maintenant puisque maintenant il
est bien évident que vu qu'il va ya
beaucoup moins de passagers eh bien ce
sont les avions de taille moyenne ou de
petite taille qui vont avoir la faveur
des compagnies aériennes et donc il ya
des quantités de gros porteurs dont les
boeing 777 qui eux aussi vont être
victimes de cette situation et cela
probablement pour quelques années
alors michel polacco c'est bien dommage
pour les passagers je sais pas si vous
allez on est d'accord mais c'est vrai
que cet a380 est extrêmement confortable
qui pour le remplacer par ce qu'on a pu
747 on a pu donc l'a380 le trick le set
vous dit tu vas être remisés lui aussi
ça veut dire qu'on va faire douze heures
de vol 14 heures pour les pays du du de
l'asie du sud est avec des avions
beaucoup plus petit et beaucoup moins
confortable
alors en fait si vous voulez ce qui va
se passer et qui était hélas une
hypothèse envisageable ou prévisible
c'est que les très gros porteurs vont
globalement disparaître et qu'on va
utiliser des avions comme l'airbus a321
xlr qui est le best-seller d'airbus
actuellement qui sont des avions de 200
220 places capable de faire huit à huit
mille huit 9000 kilomètres et qui vont
arriver à être rentables c'est à dire 80
90 % de remplissage sur des lignes
moyens ou très long courrier l'airbus
350 le boeing 787 sont des avions qui en
fait correspondre aux modules qui va et
ssaire dans les années à venir c'est à
dire entre 300 et 400 passagers et entre
eux douze heures et 18 heures de vol par
exemple vous avez vu le record qui a
battu un airbus 350 entre tahiti et la
métropole qui d'ailleurs avait rattrapé
un record battu par un boeing 787 peu de
temps avant donc voilà on est en train
d'abandonner les modules de 5 6 7 8 100
places et plus sexy dit pour l'instant
et on est en train de se re miser entre
200 et 400 places alors c'est fini et ça
sera ma dernière question c'est fini
pour air france met enfin l'a380 peut
encore compter sur des compagnies comme
emirates qui remplissent ses avions avec
peut-être moins de coûts fixes alors
évidemment si vous laissez avion ils
vont pas être détruit il faut pas croire
regret quelques-uns qui sont les
premiers modèles qui ont été construits
et qui n'étaient pas tous aux standards
de l'a380 qui vont être déconstruit ou
qui ont commencé à être déconstruites
rien à 2 mais en fait non sont des
avions qui vont être utilisés par des
compagnies qui vont les acheter pas très
cher puisqu'il va le plus très cher ils
sont amortis ils ont entre 5 et 15 ans
en gros donc ils vont pas coûter très
cher
nous devons être utilisé par des
compagnies qui vont faire certainement
de la haute densité sur des lignes moyen
ou long courrier qui seront évidemment
pas les compagnies majeures que sont
lufthansa air france grand à singapour
etc
mais le des entreprises des compagnies
comme emirates je pense vont continuer à
utiliser au moins la moitié de leur
flotte c'est à dire 60 avions sur 120 et
beaucoup de compagnies de ce genre vont
continuer à utiliser des airbus 380 on
pourra prendre ces avions encore pendant
longtemps ils sont loin d'être vieux et
d'être dépassé c'est une bonne nouvelle
merci michel polacco d'avoir été avec
nous restez avec nous donc quelques
instants nous partirons aux états unis
par un a380 a priori nous donner le
trump hausse encore le ton sur la
question du corona virus par la chine
pékin qui exhorte washington a cessé de
rejeter la faute sur son pays puis nous
irons en amérique latine qui est la
région du monde qui enregistre le plus
de nouveaux 4 coronavirus
[Musique]
certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une chaîne française d'autres affirment
même que nous ne sommes pas journalistes
mais vous
[Musique]
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons la
liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes cette diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même si
on écoute ceux qui ne sont pas d'accord
[Musique]
ici on invite les plus compétents pas
seulement ceux qui parlent le plus fort
[Musique]
ici on reçoit c'est qu'on me vois pas
ailleurs
[Musique]
alors ce coup ci c'est interdit
d'interdire
[Musique]
c'est chacun pour soi dieu pour tous cet
écho politique n'a jamais été obligé de
dire la vérité d idée courageuse des
mots qui comptent en soir vient des
lignes en gauche l'extrême
tous les témoins de notre époque sont
dans la grande interview
[Musique]
21h30 merci nous rejoindre en direct sur
rt france aux états unis le bilan
quotidien lié aux comics 19 des décès
est donc reparti à la hausse 1561 morts
en 24 heures au total on dénombre plus
de 93 mille morts depuis le début de
l'épidémie
s'il est en recul à new york d'accord
pas je vis à leurs foyers sont apparus
ailleurs comme la région de washington
où un hôpital de campagne a été installé
lundi conséquence une fausse procession
funéraire a été organisé devant la
maison blanche par des manifestants pour
dénoncer la gestion de la crise par
donald trump plusieurs états pensent
déjà à rouvrir alors qu'on n'a même pas
fait le deuil
en tant que pays de tous les gens qui
ont déjà perdu la vie et donc je pense
que ce qu'on fait ici c'est qu'on crée
un espace on reconnaissait personne en
tant que victime du virus est victime de
l'inaction du président beaucoup de
familles différentes sont déjà impacté
par le cos vide et on sait que ce sont
les latinos les communautés noires qui
sont énormément impactés on veut
s'assurer que les précautions
appropriées soient prises et que le
président les prennent pour notre
communauté et pour tout le monde parce
qu'honnêtement tout le monde est
impactée en ce moment la gestion de la
crise sanitaire donald trump lui martèle
depuis plusieurs semaines que le lourd
bilan mondial du comme il aurait pu être
évitée si la chine avait mieux géré et
des mieux réagi pardon dès l'apparition
du virus haouran réaction de pékin qui
menace de rétorsions en cas de sanctions
américaines
le gouvernement chinois estime avoir
toujours été ouvert transparent et
responsable et coûté cinq ans dix une
goutte d'eau dans la lutte contre
l'épidémie le gouvernement chinois a
adopté une attitude ouverte transparente
et responsable
nous avons parlé avec vérité les gens
peuvent voir clairement qui est celui
qui fait le plus d'efforts pour protéger
la vie et la santé des gens et
promouvoir la coopération interne
ciot nal contre l'épidémie nous pensons
que l'équité se trouve dans le coeur de
chacun pour en parler nous sommes en
direct depuis new york aux états unis
avec vanessa chausseterre res berg
journaliste indépendante et notre
rubrique vu de l'extérieur ce soir
[Musique]
bonsoir nsa schuster iceberg
merci d'être avec nous sur rt france
pour évoquer donc la situation aux
etats-unis avec notamment on l'a
développée en cette manifestation devant
la maison blanche selon vous c'est une
colère partagée aujourd'hui par beaucoup
d'américains la gestion de la crise par
donald trump
cela fait trois mois de confinement pour
les américains la situation devient très
dur pour les gens
cela a également des effets sur
l'économie
au fait à ce jour les 50 états ont
commencé leur confinement mais le 50d
9050 approche différente
certains m'ont rapidement d'autres ' je
prenne des précautions plus stricte par
exemple en matière d distanciation
sociale sans matière est connu et
sociales effectivement les américains
commencent à se sentir un peu désespéré
après trois mois de confinement
s'explique selon vous cette colère parce
que là pour le coup c'était vraiment
dirigé vers la maison blanche est ce que
donald trump n'a pas commis des erreurs
dans la gestion de cette crise
aujourd'hui ils accusent la chine la
chine qui dit justement que c'est pour
se dédouaner de ses propres failles
la situation est effectivement vrai que
donald trump aurait pu agir plus
rapidement par exemple pour ça mais le
pays est ce que cette colère et c est
justement un bon titre vers le président
ce n'est pas clair le président trump la
chine cherche effectivement à venir la
chine pour son manque de réactivité
durant la pandémie
cependant elle reste également prudent
en vue des élections
nous avons beaucoup de commerce avec la
chine
donc ils marchent sur des oeufs vous
parliez
voilà vous affirmez en tout cas vont
vous semblez dire que donald trump on ne
sait pas trop si la colère de la
population est vraiment dirigés contre
lui il n'empêche vu de l'extérieur de
notre homme peut avoir des sorties un
petit peu étonnante son histoire d'eau
de javel et plus récemment la
prisonniers de roxy chloroquine à titre
préventif comment sont perçus justement
ses originalités
si l'on puis dire de donald trump par
les américains on ne sait jamais à quoi
s'attendre de la part du président trop
nous c'est certain mais surtout
lorsqu'il s'agit de ses tweets tardive
dans la journée s'agissant de
l'hydroxyde chloroquine effectivement la
circule pas mal de membres de la
communauté scientifique
ce médicament ne l'est pas approuvés
pour la lutte contre le virus mais pour
la lui même et le parti sous d'autres
maladies du même genre donc que la
communauté scientifique a été perturbée
déroutés par ces affirmations et dans
les médias m'a questionné cette idée
qu'il prenait déjà la drogue sur lui
de la country on n'a pas été dépisté
comme étant malade pourquoi prendrait-il
ce médicament vous avez parlé de la
campagne pour la présidentielle en
imagine qui doit être un petit peu éludé
par cette crise du coronavirus et le
moins qu'on puisse dire et vous parliez
justement de ses rapports avec la chine
cette passe d'armes avec pékin on
rappelle que donald trump accusent la
chine de tueries de masse
est ce que le président américain ont
fait un élément principal de sa campagne
présidentielle selon vous à skis c'est
qu'ils dosent what you say neuf soit
vite en quelques sortes à gémir la chine
peut nier que les autres et manque
d'action alors de cette crise il se
trouvait seul face à aux élections avec
des choses à beaucoup de ses électeurs
qui voulaient un renforcement un
communiqué s'agissant cet accord
commercial avec la chine qui est censé
acheter des biens aux états unis à
hauteur de plusieurs milliards de
dollars
c'est jude on est vraiment dans une
position d'équilibriste
il veut faire porter la gravité sur la
chine
s'agissant de la pandémie mais en même
temps il doit obtenir cet accord
commercial afin de revivifier l'économie
américaine vous êtes actuellement à new
york
un mot peut-être sur la situation
sanitaire qui a encore quelques semaines
était dramatique est ce que les choses
s'améliorent un petit peu à new york où
vous êtes trois mois je reste à la
maison avec ma famille est effectivement
personnellement c'est une situation
assez dur mais on sort à peine quelques
nuits par jour en général cependant
admis oui je sais que cette équipe
grande région que l'état de new york qui
sont en train de se dégonfler les des
précautions très importante
n'importe où même à ce qu'on regarde ses
distances cependant la ville de new york
mon corps se dé confiné selon
l'estimation dont le gouverneur puis
qu'on est encore longue et dès qu'on
fait une main qui voudraient bien sortir
de chez eux
la météo s'améliore est certaine les
célèbres memorial day
une des grandes célébrations en arrêter
avec les gens feront sortir de la ville
est strictement surveillés ya beaucoup
de policiers dans les rues qui surveille
que les gens ferment la distanciation
social qu'ils portent des masques mais
avec la proche de l'été d'institutions
devenir de plus en plus tendue que je
fais gagner a ajouté que l'état de new
york doit affronter une nouvelle grappe
de cas c'est plutôt une maladie nouvelle
qui semble frapper les enfants des
enfants qui
la vie inflammatoires nouvelle c'est un
nouvel aspect de la crise du coronavirus
et le maire de new york et le gouverneur
de l'état doivent étudier situation de
très près et très sérieusement jeu
rebondit rapidement sur cette dernière
remarque parce qu'elle est importante ce
qu'il s'agit peut-être du syndrome de
kawasaki dont on a aussi parlé en
français dont on ne sait pas encore
formellement s'il est liée aux
eaux-vives 19 ça touche les enfants new
yorkais tout à fait 157 enfants
diagnostiqués avec la le saint georges
de gaza les enfants qui ont été dépistés
avait également des anticorps on essaye
de comprendre ce qu'est ce syndrome et
quels sont ses liens avec le court
navires us merci à vous vanessa schuster
réserve d'avoir été avec nous ce soir
pour vu de l'extérieur merci et si le
nombre de cas de kobe 19 est en baisse
en europe il est en forte hausse en
amérique latine c'est un facteur de
crise sociale au chili près de cinquante
cinq mille 4 confirmés et 544 morts avec
plus de 4000 nouveaux cas et 35 décès
ces dernières 24 heures soit la plus
forte hausse dans le pays
l'armée s'est déployée dans des
quartiers pauvres de santiago la
population s'est affrontés avec la
police
et puis au pire ou la situation
également alarmante c'est le deuxième
pays le plus touché du continent après
le brésil
le personnel soignant dénonce les
pénurie d'équipements et de médicaments
dans les hôpitaux
le pérou est toujours en confinement
depuis plus de neuf semaines
et puis au brésil à présent aux
interrogations sur le système de santé
sur le sort des populations les plus
pauvres est le pays épicentre du virus
sur le continent a dépassé le cap des
1000 décès en 24 heures et la table de
18 mille morts et face à ces chiffres le
gouvernement préconise désormais l'
usage de la chloroquine aux patients
légèrement atteints auparavant il était
utilisé pour traiter des cas graves une
mesure après les pressions du président
jean pierre bolle sonar haut pour un
usage généralisé par la population
le médicament est déjà en rupture de
stock dans plusieurs villes du brésil
la demande de chloroquine est très élevé
et nous pensons qu'elle est efficace
nous n'avons plus de stock nous n'en
avons plus du tout nous essayons d'en
chercher avec les distributeurs mais
c'est vraiment difficile pour nous d'y
arriver car la demande pour ce
médicament est immense malheureusement
nous n'avons même pas besoin de montrer
nous sommes en rupture de stock en ce
moment je t'ai cette responsabilité sur
les gens c'est comme s'essuyer les mains
le ministère de la santé s'essuie les
mains sur ce qui va arriver aux citoyens
je ne crois pas du tout à la chloroquine
il n'y a pas de preuve et les ministres
n'accepte pas de l'utiliser mais en
équateur autres pays d'amérique latine
fortement touché par la pandémie des
familles victimes ont décidé d'attaquer
l'état en justice
ils n'ont pas de nouvelles du corps de
leur proche mort du co vite 19 avec plus
de 30 mille cas et près de 3000 décès le
pays commence néanmoins à alléger
certaines mesures de confinement prend
ce rang soit ce qu'évite ch
il y as foule dans les rues de guayaquil
depuis ce mercredi cette ville portuaire
épicentre de la pandémie de coronavirus
dans le pays
assoupli certaines mesures de
restriction fini le couvre-feu de 15
heures par jours instaurée depuis neuf
semaines
il est dorénavant limitée entre 21h et
5h du matin fini aussi le télétravail
obligatoire le travail présentiel étant
désormais autorisées mais limitées à 50
% du personnel les transports publics
urbains et des activités commerciales
eux sont rétablis tout le monde est
d'accord pour dire qu'il faut sortir
tout le monde mais seulement par
nécessité mais nous sommes tous inquiets
de la trappe et ça c'est sûr
nous sommes tous inquiets mais on doit
sortir pour acheter du pain
de toute façon le gouvernement ne nous
aide pas ils nous ont bien un sentiment
d'abandon partagé par de nombreux
équatorien comme ces familles de
victimes qui manifestent devant le
tribunal de la ville sans nouvelles du
corps de leur proche mort du co vie 19
elles ont décidé d'attaquer l'état
équatorien
mon père est mort le 1er avril les
médecins légistes sont venus le chercher
le lendemain il devait m'appeler mais
ils ne l'ont pas fait jusqu'à
aujourd'hui
depuis on essaye de savoir pourquoi et
ils ne disent rien sur mon père
il n'y a eu aucune réponse de la
présidence de la république ni du comité
des opérations d'urgence
ils ont éludé leurs responsabilités et
cela les rend coupable de toutes les
actions que nous allons prendre des
familles de victimes qui doivent
également faire face aux dettes de
plusieurs milliers de dollars contracté
par leurs proches
les hôpitaux publics submergé
l'assistance médicale privée souvent la
seule option pour les malades du
coronavirus une option coûteuse entre
400 à 800 dollars par journées
d'hospitalisation et entre 1500 et 2500
dollars en soins intensifs
alors que le salaire minimum en équateur
ne dépasse pas les 400 dollars par mois
or évoqué la situation en équateur nous
sommes en direct avec gabriella bravo
journaliste chilienne bonsoir gabriela
bravo merci d'être avec nous l'équateur
mais plus globalement l'amérique latine
nouvel épicentre de la pandémie comment
peut-on l'expliquer selon vous en soirée
en fait là l'épidémie suit le cours
normal d'une épidémie qui commence dans
la partie orientée blog et qui passe
après vers l'occident est passé d'un la
chine jusqu'en europe
et après c'est le cas de l'amérique
celle faux normal d'une épidémie mais
c'est ce qu'il faut dire c'est que en
amérique du sud
on est dans une période hors m d'automne
on est dans l'otan est prêt à passer à
l'intérieur hivernale c'est qui peut à
vous faire agrandir cette épidémie qui
puisse se développer encore plus dans le
continent que par exemple en europe
comme si on était en train de passer
vers 30 ans une chose sans importance et
que à dire c'est que cette épidémie a
été ramené par des voyageurs va vous
surtout des gens aisés qui voyageait en
europe ou en asie
et c'est eux qui sont ramenés la maladie
l'épidémie dans le continent américain
car effectivement chacun ramène
au jour de toute façon la maladie dans
un pays c'était le cas également en
europe
comment est perçue la gestion des
gouvernements des pays d'amérique latine
on parle beaucoup notamment du brésil
avec gestion un petit peu particulière
de jaillir un bol so now qui est
toujours au corona sceptiques et qui
suscite les inquiétudes de certains
observateurs dans cette gestion de la
crise on peut voir qu'elle est juste qu
ils sont assez différents d'un pays à
l'autre mais en général
l'amérique latine n'a pas bien réagi à
cette épidémie
d'une part parce que les différences
économiques entre et les écarts entre
les riches et les pauvres sont énormes
l'accès à la santé n'est pas égalité et
passons pour donner un chiffre trop
sonder la population de l'amérique
latine ne peut pas se soigner
correctement puisque par des récents
économique et 20% de la population ne
pas accès à la santé par des raisons
géographiques
alors les présidents les les politiciens
en fait ils ont essayé de mettre des
mesures restrictives comme des
quarantaines dans certaines régions dont
d'en haut des quarantaines donc la
population mais par des récents et qu'on
a mis kc-45 nom a été respecté
complètement n'ont pas été suivies pour
la population on a souligné que dans
plusieurs pays notamment les états unis
et même la france ce sont les
populations souvent défavorisées qui
était davantage touchés par ce
coronavirus on imagine que
c'est la même chose justement dans ces
pays d'amérique latine où vous venez de
le dire le fossé entre les pauvres et
les riches et est très accentué
exactement c'est parce que en amérique
latine le travail informel atteint un
niveau très élevé
selon l' organisation internationale du
travail jusqu'à 50% de la population de
l'amérique latine fait un travail
informel la sécurité sociale n'est pas
comme ici comment on les repous ya pas d
chômage dans tous les pays
seulement quelques était donc destinée
aux gens qui sont dans le besoin
pour donner un exemple par exemple le
chili et la rentrée en quarantaine au
total dans la région dans la capitale et
a provoqué des émeutes de la faim parce
qu'il ya des gens qui n'arrivent pas à
se nourrir et nourrir correctement
lula a vu qu'ils sont pas de travail pas
se nourrir justement il ya eu des
manifestations anti confinement
certainement pour ces raisons
économiques que vous évoquez ans au
brésil notamment est-ce que ça a été le
cas également dans d'autres pays
d'amérique latine des gens qui voulaient
justement condé confine pour pouvoir
aller travailler simplement
après les récents entre le faciles et
d'autres pays sont différents parce que
on voit par exemple au brésil c'est des
manifestations comme on peut voir en
amérique du nord aux états unis pour
laisser l'économie suivre son cours
normal pendant que par son plein au
chili en colombie un simple en colombie
les gens mais des chiffons rouges dans
les maisons pour montrer qu'ils sont
qu'il demande de la nourriture qui le
demandaient l'argent de l'état or pour
que l'état ne le savons pas je suis
sérieux parce que on vient de le roy on
avait eu une révolte sociale d'une
ampleur énorme d'encore hier les
coronavirus
les mettant un peu en ag les un peu les
conflit social dans l'amérique latine
mais il y avait aussi ces m une loupe
pour voir les groupes différence qu'il
ya entre les riches et les pauvres donc
plus calmé la colère sociale
cette épidémie bien faire une des
augmentations de tous ces conflits et il
fait la sortir de la pire façon possible
et c'est à travers l'énorme quantité de
mots surtout des populations les
favoriser merci beaucoup
gabriella bravo nous avoir évoqué cette
situation en amérique latine et on
traverse à présent l'atlantique le
coronavirus qui pourrait pousser le
liban et tout le moyen-orient vers une
crise alimentaire majeure
avertissement ce jeudi du premier
ministre libanais hassan diab qui a même
appelé la communauté internationale à
mettre en place un fonds urgent pour
aider cette région faire face à une
possible famine la pandémie qui a
contaminé près d'un millier de personnes
et entraîné la mort de 26 personnes au
liban est la même et aide le liban vis
pire crise économique depuis la fin de
la guerre civile
il y a vingt ans une situation
dramatique qui dure depuis neuf mois et
qui est amplifié par les mesures de
confinement liêu coronavirus la livre
libanaise a perdu à plus de la moitié de
sa valeur face au dollar
les projections d'inflation sont
propulsés à plus de 50% sur l'année 2020
et d'après les estimations officielles
près d'un habitant sur deux vit
actuellement sous le seuil de pauvreté
ce jeudi beyrouth a tenté de rassurer la
population le chef du gouvernement
libanais s'est engagé à freiner la
dégringolade de la monnaie nationale et
à subventionner les produits de base et
j'annonce ici que les procédures ont
déjà commencé le gouverneur de la banque
centrale m'a promis que la banque du
liban interviendrait sur le marché dès
maintenant pour protéger la livre
libanaise
et freiner la hausse du taux de change
j'annonce également que l'importation de
produits alimentaires de base sera
subventionné selon un calendrier fixe
qu'il y aura un suivi quotidien afin de
réduire les prix des denrées
alimentaires et que les libanais à
sisteron bientôt à une baisse des prix
de ses produits
un discours tenus à l'occasion du
centième jour de l'entrée en fonction du
gouvernement dans un pays en pleine
débâcle financière
jadis le grenier à blé de l'est de la
méditerranée le liban fait face à un
risque d'une crise alimentaire majeure
d'après les autorités
de nombreux libanais ont par exemple
cessé d'acheter de la viande des fruits
et des légumes
il pourrait même bientôt avoir du mal à
se payer du pain et une population à
bout et qui est confronté depuis
plusieurs jours à des coupures de
courant dans certaines régions des
habitants se retrouvent sans électricité
pendant près de 12 heures défilé un
ras-le-bol que certains libanais ont
exprimé ce jeudi en tentant de pénétrer
dans les locaux du ministère de
l'énergie dans la capitale les
manifestants ont notamment scandé des
slogans contre la corruption et le
gaspillage de l'argent public l'état
corrompu nous a coupé l'électricité
il y à de l'électricité au palais
présidentiel dans le bâtiment du
gouvernement
il vole de milliards de dollars par an
apporter un milliard de dollars à
dépenser en électricité et garder
l'autre milliards pour vous mais soulagé
nous nous allons nous débarrasser de
vous face à la crise économique les
manifestations anti-gouvernement donc
repris depuis plus de trois semaines
malgré le confinement liban un pays qui
croule sous une dette de 92 milliards de
dollars soit 170 % du pib
en octobre dernier la crise économique
avait déjà été l'un des déclencheurs
d'un soulèvement inédit contre la classe
politique accusée de corruption et
d'incompétence
c'est la fin de cette émission merci
d'avoir suivi prochain point complet sur
l'actualité ce sera dans quelques
minutes pour un journal
est resté à déconcerter france
[Musique]